six rip
i take that back six to three lenovo
breaks the seal
uber is layup is the first time he
touched it
beautifully
[Applause]
perfect textbook defense get it with
your outside hand
good help right there good recognition
by mason
deflected pass
loose picked up by bridges
[Applause]
lamelo
[Applause]
look them all
with a dribble in the eyes pull them up
three he's got a bag full of games
[Music]
[Applause]
31 from there last year yeah i mean
lavella pokes it free sets up
just set him up so nicely
to get a good look
third
second quarter triple for lavello
when you get you free throws like he can
you're always wanted
[Applause]
numbers for indiana
there he is number 11. and miles saves
it
[Applause]
right here just deflections that keep
track of that
that saves it
again
[Applause]
[Music]
yes he meant to do that
excellent play ubrey could have forced a
shot right there he said no we got good
momentum
where's my point guard
corner three duarte
not falling
[Applause]
halfway through our third quarter
this guy
loves to play the game
let's play under the screen holiday
that's a mistake easy
knock that one in and hold the follow
through
so well on the other side of the ball
pardon been down by oh
[Applause]
[Music]
just in case you forgot
number two was in the game
oh let it be known
got to call someone's name with duarte
and he has come through
[Applause]
for the time
he meant to die
look at that pass
and
as long as that ball is on line when
you're at the top
hayward
looking for help
branches
[Applause]